a couple of years ago from a mat who
works for us he gave me a gift
is he the christmas or birthday stuff
because he gave it to me too
he gave me this piece of paper that said
he had bought uh 50
worth of bitcoin for me and i forgot
about this thing i threw it right in the
garbage i was like i don't know what
bitcoin is
i don't i don't pay attention to this
[ __ ] and i even said to him
how do i redeem my 50 how do i go on the
internet why not 50 i'm not gonna throw
away fifty dollars
he didn't even know him he didn't know
yeah yeah it seems to me
i don't even know how you get this so
the other day mamet was running around
here talking about what a financial
genius he is because
the cryptocurrency now has like gone
through the roof
so he was going around bragging telling
people that he's smarter than i
am and that he knows about finance and
look how bright he was
how rich is he um well that's what i
said so i said hey did somebody tell me
now
momet must be a very wealthy man how
much did he invest in bitcoin
zero he didn't invest a dime in it
that's how smart he is
right well you guys had made me feel so
stupid for being
interested in bitcoin in the first place
i mean but first of all i didn't want to
say i was
smarter than you i just wanted to say i
believe i'm smarter
than you give me credit for and this is
just one more example
oh please it's not an example you didn't
buy
in don't tell everybody that we
discouraged you
you claim to know something well again i
i do i did look up to you two at the
time and now i know what a terrible
mistake that is
i told you not to look up to me here
i'll play the clip this is my met on the
show and i
i did i blew up at you i will play the
club all i know is he sent me a card and
then there was like a piece of paper in
there that said i had bitcoin for 50. i
just thought oh
okay i'll spend this somewhere yeah like
what do i do
it away how about just giving me 50
[ __ ] dollars
right robin we don't want bitcoin i'll
buy my own bitcoin right if i want
bitcoin
i'll get it give me fifty dollars i'll
give you back that
shitty piece of paper you gave me
listen to the listen to the haughtiness
there i mean i
like i love robin and she gave me uh she
gave me
champagne for christmas which was very
nice but like imagine if
there's something but there's something
you can use
imagine if i said moment if i wanted
champagne i'd buy champagne i mean you'd
think i was the biggest no
that is not that is not the same thing
we know what champagne is
none of us knew how including you to
redeem the bitcoin
stock for when he grows up he doesn't
know what a stock is that doesn't mean
it wasn't a great what
gracious gift i'm done with this thank
you howard can i just
can i say one thing about this so you
know and it was gracious that he gave it
to me for christmas
but when i when i got it i tried to
figure out how to redeem it there's no
way and then
momet looked into it he goes i can't
figure it out either but you should
really look into it because it's going
to be valuable so mamet said you know
he said hey what i gave you is probably
worth around three hundred dollars and i
still have it
no one knows how to redeem it no one no
one including my mat
i mean take two seconds to google how to
cash the damn we did
we did remember everybody did you looked
into it you looked into it you're like
yeah i give up
but if you had it mimet you could have
told us all
how to redeem it smart
you're smarter than us we're not going i
never said i'm
smarter than you what good
is bitcoin if we can't get our money out
of it please
no more terrible for you thank you